[Musique]
notre c'est avec jean luc landry et jean
martin aussant bonsoir messieurs et
joyeux anniversaire monsieur à sa merci
beaucoup c'est gentil voilà une petite
année de plus derrière la cravate
quelques unes je commence avec vous jean
martin air canada 20 millions de
motivation pour les dirigeants malgré la
crise malgré l'aide fédérale malgré
vingt mille emplois supprimés est-ce que
c'est acceptable
ben je pense que non absolument pas pu
rassembler toujours pas c'est un peu la
même chose quand on a des nouvelles
comme ça si ces gens là étaient des gens
qui avaient inventé l'avion ou qui
avaient fait des grandes découvertes en
aéronautique qui bénéficie à toute
l'humanité
peut-être que ça vaudrait la peine qu'on
les rémunèrent avec des millions comme
ça même quand ça va moins bien
mais ce sont des gens qui finalement
font partie d'un groupe sélect des
gestionnaires de groupe c'est l'écran
sur des gestionnaires qui sont là puis
quand j'entends le discours que si on ne
rémunère pas cette hauteur là ils vont
s'en aller mais je me dis qu'avec 8
millions de cerveau au québec puis plus
de 30 millions de cerveau au canada on
en trouverait peut-être des deux robes
aussi efficace que les leurs pour les
remplacer donc les discours qui mérite
ce salaire loeb dans le contexte il
tient absolument pas la route mais je
pense que c'est assez unanimes
d'ailleurs on va voir avec jean luc est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça je le
mettrais seulement dans le contexte par
exemple une compagnie qui dans une année
normale fait un milliard et demi de
bénéfices et donc qu'on parle de 20
millions $ pour garder un bon management
a une cohésion à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise
c'est pas une participation aux
bénéfices
évidemment il n'y a pas de bénéfices ces
bonnes ils sont des bonis pour atteindre
de performance
donc j'ai un problème c'est qu'elle est
la performance à peine alors qu'air
canada elle opère mais j'écris dans la
note de jean martin je pense que le mot
le plus important pour moi c'est
peut-être qu'on peut les remplacer
moi comme manager là je prendrai pas de
chance cette compagnie là à tourner
c'était une compagnie littéralement
morimont très inefficace tous les
clients la détestais aujourd'hui je
l'accompagnais rentable qui va bien
je crois pas qu'avec l'amour d'air
canada a grandi aujourd'hui juste un
petit point là dessus c'est que
quelqu'un donc pas une histoire de
manière exagérée
c'est pas mon mardi la colère enescu a
tourné cette compagnie là et c'est boni
était possible et rien que ça en termes
comparables sur owni les dix mieux pays
vous avez sûrement vu son talent dans
les bonnes idées président c'est 10 à 20
millions ar priz là alors ici on parle
de jeu juste met en perspective
je sais jamais millions pour l'ensemble
du management mais la même perspective
c'est perte nette de 4 milliards 600
millions 6 et 5 600 millions de
subvention salariale cés 20000 employés
qui ont perdu leur emploi ça fait aussi
partie de la perspective quand on décide
de donner une prime de motivation est ce
qu'on a besoin à ce point de motiver
michael rousseau qui elle est revenue
secouer compagnie qui paye sur les
actionnaires qui paye les bains les
fonctions non non non non excusez moi là
c'est pas vrai il ya eu des préfère
canada des termes avantage oublions les
proches d'eux parce que des programmes
forts ces policiers ça vient après le
prêt mais le site de 5 600 millions de
subventions salariales pour payer les
salaires ça ait de l'entreprise air
canada ce ça aide c'était une politique
gouvernementale disponible pour tout le
monde
elle est utilisée c'est possible et sur
air canada plus spécifiquement je
penserai le défendre le 20 millions
changerait de le mettre en perspective
simplement
mais je vous dis une chose je vais pas
payer zéro boni chez air canada cette
année auxquels jean martin nous oui
parce que je connais pas leur politique
de rémunération et terme dans le
contexte ça avec tout ce qui s'est passé
il ya des entreprises qui auraient pas
dû verser des dividendes ou traversée de
bonnes ils l'ont fait quand même et je
pense que celle des tâches la population
de cette entreprise là et du modèle
économique actuel laquelle on vit ça les
fait le décrédibilise parce que les
jeunes énormément jackson souffrait mais
pour gagner au programme pour garder des
des hauts dirigeants
il faut absolument verser des primes
jean martin mais je pense que le système
ait rendu un peu malade quand on dit que
ça prend 10 millions pour garder chef de
la direction
c'est pas toujours du bon sens là comme
je le disais tantôt si son entrepreneur
qui est développée grand vrai quand est
un logiciel tout le monde mais je trouve
qui mérite son salaire mais quand ce
sont des gestionnaires qui sont juste
chanceux d'être l'api qui se nomment
entre eux d'ailleurs et qui skie des
traders politique de rémunération entre
eux c'est là que les bus fait vraiment
mal et c'est ça écoeure la population ah
bon québécois sur la subvention
salariale
la subvention salariale existe depuis le
début de la pandémie
beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont touché la
subvention salariale plusieurs centaines
d'entreprises dont plusieurs ont vu
leurs revenus augmenter leurs profits
est en croissance
une entreprise comme tf1 transport au
québec a fait très acquisitions a vu ses
revenus et ses profits augmenter costard
qui a fait 3 milliards 700 millions de
profits à toucher la subvention
salariale
jean luc est ce que la subvention
salariale est trop généreuse
non non je pense pas d'ailleurs toute
l'année passée à la fois jean martin et
moi nous étions d'accord pour faire plus
plus tôt que moi et maintenant qu'on a
le résultat qui un retour ultra rapide
au sortir de cette réunion les sessions
là je crois pas que je vais revenir en
arrière
on a trop fait on a l'objectif était de
revenir vite et on a vu et ses revenus
deuxième point je peux me permettre si
on était aux états unis je vous dirais
que c'est complètement insensé
les programmes fédéraux américains sont
complètement
ils ont perdu la carte mais c'est pas le
cas au canada donc jean martin moi je
pense que le canada était trop généreux
mais tous les gouvernements ont été trop
généreux et c'est pas parce qu'ils le
voulaient c'est parce que les programmes
fait dans la hâte
donc je pense que s'il y avait plus de
temps il ya eu des conditions
d'admissibilité peut-être même peut-être
des clauses de remboursement si les
choses vont bien mais ça a été fait
tellement rapide mc sais c'est dur de
critiquer qu'on en était trop comme le
dit jean luc donc je pense qu'on était
trop généreux mais on n'avait pas le
choix à l'époque parfait je vous emmène
sur les tomates demers et ce reportage
qui fait beaucoup parler
des travailleurs étrangers agricole
leurs conditions de travail leurs
conditions de vie en fait pour ces
travailleurs là jean le comment doivent
réagir
les partenaires publics les partenaires
privés face à une entreprise comme ça
moi je suis même pas capable de
comprendre comment ça c'est qu'on
subventionne cette entreprise-là
leglaire demain vos maîtres autour de 60
millions de dollars dans cette
entreprise là qui exploite de chip
leader
elle n'ose même pas d'emploi aux
québécois parce que les québécois
veulent pas de ces conditions
travaillent là ils sont pas bonnes
alors pourquoi on met de l'argent pour
des conditions de travail qui sont pas
bonnes
je ne peux pas me l'expliquer ok gens
m'appellent je trouve ça c'est difficile
de justifier seul quand on se rend
compte d'abord via les médias de ce qui
se passe sur son propre terrain sont
plus tristes et quand on dit qu'on
respectait les normes
il ya peut-être un problème avec les
normes si c'est vrai bien le gros bon
5,7 autonome ou si si je vous disais ce
soir je vous fais une salade puis je
mets tout petit soupçon d'arsenic de
dames est en dessous des dames est-ce
que vous la margerie
il ya gros bon sens qui s'applique donc
je pense que c'est très difficile de
justifier alors fait ces deux sujets là
je trouve montre que le système
économique que vous êtes un peu il est
un peu car si les profits à tout prix ça
marche papy l'école le fruit de même que
la seule responsabilité sociale d'une
entreprise c'est faire des profits les
personnes qui croient ça sur quelques
spécimens qu'on connaît peut-être mais
il faut sortir de ce modèle la devise
refuge humain neuf jeunes essayant de
vous répondre car je pense vous dire non
c'est que le modèle de modèles de
recherche de profits complètement
chimiques et personnes croient cela
c'est parce que j'ai dit ok je vous fais
entendre les réactions de françois
legault pour vous demander de réagir
ensuite françois legault
j'espère que c'est un cas isolé le
ministre agriculture de la montagne
parlé avec monsieur demers qui ont dit
qu'ils n'étaient pas corriger la
situation on va mettre les travailleurs
dans d'autres logements faut comprendre
que pour ce qui est du rôle du
gouvernement c'est plus le gouvernement
fédéral qui doit s'assurer que les
conditions sont bonnes pour les
travailleurs temporaires qui viennent au
canada mais moi je trouve ça
inacceptable
je te contente de voir que monsieur
demers pensent la même chose pour vos
voeux et fort qu objet la situation
donc monsieur demers veuves au corriger
la situation le gouvernement fédéral
doit s'occuper des travailleurs
étrangers de leur condition
mais jean luc hess que le gouvernement
du québec a un travail à frère par
rapport à tout son soutien financier à
une entreprise qui s'appelle tomates
demers battue regardez c'est une erreur
financement du triple-double de
l'étranger les québécois c contient la
compagnie est obligée d'offrir des
mauvaises conditions de travail pour
être concurrentiel alors les vestes sont
pas là dedans monsieur legault le dit
lui-même il veut que les immigrants
viennent ici gagne 55 milles et plus par
année
mais là on a déjà sonné vesti dans une
entreprise qui est obligé de payer à la
mi novembre dernier des gens de
l'étranger les éloigner de leur famille
etc
rhodes en ville dortoir ça marche pas
c'est qu'un plan d'affaires de son le
dernier mot jean marc est là dessus bien
d'accord s'il faut des conditions de
salubrité pour quel modèle d'affaires
soit viable n'est pas viable modèle
d'affaires donc j'espère que ça et
corrigée rapidement par c'est quand même
une entreprise qu'il faut dix
l'alimentation au québec il ya
clairement des choses à corriger
ok on s'arrête ici jean martin aussant
joyeux anniversaire jean luc landry
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh